antoine bonjour alors quel est
l'objectif de cette conférence qui se
tient dans la capitale syrienne plus de
cinq millions et demi de syriens ont fui
leur pays depuis le début des hostilités
depuis le début du conflit il ya
maintenant près de dix ans et le
gouvernement syrien cherche maintenant
avec ce genre d'initiative à les faire
revenir mais les obstacles sont nombreux
déficit d'infrastructures sanctions
internationales contre la syrie
situation humanitaire et économique
parfois mais aussi situation sécuritaire
parfois délicate dans certaines régions
sans même parler de l'enclavé d'idleb
toujours sous contrôle terroriste autant
de thématiques de problématiques qui
font l'objet ici dans le cadre de cette
conférence de discussion cette
conférence justement est organisée par
les autorités syriennes avec le concours
et le soutien de la russie mais aussi la
participation d'autres pays tels que le
liban voisin qui accueille à lui seul
près d'un million et demi de réfugiés
l'onu est également présente en qualité
d'observateur au contraire de l'union
européenne pourtant invité mais qui a
finalement décliné s'invitent cette
invitation estimant que les conditions
d'un retour des réfugiés ne sont à
l'heure actuelle pas réunies l'objectif
de cette conférence est pourtant louable
faire tomber les obstacles du moins les
atténuer ces obstacles qui empêchent à
l'heure actuelle les syriens de revenir
sur leur terre natale
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes ces précisions vous étiez en
direct de damas la capitale syrienne